lots of hardware manufacturers are  coming up with their own small steam  based gaming pcs Alienware is about to  release there's the Alienware alpha it's  packing an Intel Core i3 CPU at 2.9  gigahertz 4 gigabytes of ddr3 RAM and a  modified nvidia 860 m GPU with 2  gigabytes of vram it's priced at $550  which is more expensive than next-gen  consoles but it is competing with them  Alienware is calling it a console so  let's put it to the test we're gonna see  how this performs against a PlayStation  4 and Xbox one  you  stories Manta like nothing ever seen  before we're gonna walk away from this  man  please  slide Reagan from us  we missed one of you would not go stay  an easy mistake to face  Joubert up big foot up his hands  you